c'est vrai que c'est un débat qui est
sans fin je n'ai toujours pas compris ce
qui nous est arrivé
je parle pas de la dangerosité du virus
on sait aujourd'hui qui est un nombre de
morts qui est insupportable qu'il ya eu
des victimes que tout le monde dans son
entourage a pu souffrir de l'irruption
de ce virus dans nos vies dans nos
familles dans la société
mais il ya quand même un mec quand je
lis dans le monde en une que c'est
l'hécatombe du siècle qu'on parle de la
d'un taux de mortalité de 0 20 noeuds
0,15 pour cent de gens qui sont morts
dont l'âge médian est de 83 ans
je me dis heureusement qu'on n'a pas
vécu les sévices d'un virus qui serait
mortelle dans 50 % des cas qui
s'attaquerait aux gens entre 20 et 40
ans parce que vu comme on a paniqué pour
je vais pas dire pas grand chose ce
serait insultant pour la mémoire des
gens qui ont disparu je vais pas dire
viennent pas grand chose mais on a sans
doute céder à une panique extraordinaire
formidable alors qu' on aurait peut-être
pu avec plus de calme et de recul
gérer les choses plus intelligemment
exemple exemple cette histoire de passes
sanitaires ça veut tout dire ça résume
tout on est prêt aujourd'hui à aliéner
notre dignité est remarqué comme des
moutons avec un tatouage pour savoir si
x y ou z a ou non le sida parce que
c'est on peut très bien aller beaucoup
plus loin
si on vous autorise l au cinéma parce
que vous êtes ça on pourrait aussi vous
historisées aller au cinéma parce que
vous n'êtes pas séropositif
parce que vous êtes beau parce que vous
êtes blanc et non pas noire et je trouve
que le marquage biologique est quelque
chose d'unique d'ultra violence et je
parle de sa scierie parce que c'est bien
là le symbole du fait qu'on est capable
dans la panique de céder le peu de
dignité qui nous reste et c'est à dire
notre corps notre intimité notera
intégrité physique et le fait qu'on
puisse échanger une information sur son
intégrité physique contre la possibilité
d'aller se bâfrer dans un restaurant
même si je trouve que les restaurateurs
ont immédiatement iméo nous avons
souffert et c'est pas ça le sujet je
trouve ça indigne et c'est la preuve
même on a cédé à la panique la plus
totale je pense que dans dix ans les
sociologues et historiens riront de
l'immaturité avec laquelle on a géré
cette panique très infantile
jean paul hamon je ne sais pas aussi
les historiens verront mais franchement
je trouve que même si ça a pédalé un peu
dans la semoule au départ il ya pas eu
de panique et je peux vous dire que
quand des réanimateurs se sont trouvés
comme en italie avec le choix de dire
est ce que j'aurai anime ces personnes
de 70 ans ou est-ce que je choisi de
garder cette personne de 55 ans je vous
dire 70 ans
les mecs il ya des mecs qui pensent
qu'ils ont encore la vie devant eux
alors on peut toujours être attaquée
tout ce qu'on veut j'ai hâte et les
chemins franchement on peut aussi
arriver l'aider il était temps que le
gouvernement prenne des dispositions sur
le premier confinement parce qu'on était
au taquet sur le plan spitalier les
réanimations était plein et et là il
était temps qu'on arrête
et là encore une fois on a on va rouvrir
les terrasses demain c'est très bien je
vois les gens qui sont en train de
reconstituer à l'extérieur les
conditions de l'intérieur dans les
terrasses avait des terrasses qui sont
couvertes il ya des trucs de deux côtés
il ya du plastique tout autour les mecs
qui vont humour et talent et ils vont
être fallait il y avait à savoir entre
un tout petit peu ils sont dans les
conditions de contamination de
l'intérieur donc je suis entendu olivier
ferrand qui disent il faut enlever quand
même les panneaux sur le côté il faut
que ça circule docteur peut aller
bouffer j'avais eu avec avec un manteau
s'il fait froid qu'un parapluie
c'est bien de pouvoir se rencontrer et
ses mails à dire qu'on a paniqué alors
qu'on a quand même plus de cent mille
morts ok
cent mille morts sur une population de
combien docteur 60 millions chifa sans
régler en embêtant pour dire que non non
attendez quand on touche du doigt par
disent que tu dois marquer on va manger
les gens les gens quand les gens vont au
restaurant quand il va au ciné etc
c'est très bien que jean maxime sauvé
attendait au mois de septembre avec 50%
de français qui est des comptes le
vaccin là maintenant les mecs qui se
battent pour se faire vacciner mais
c'est très bientôt de bonnes choses on
va vacciner 85 90 % des français
mélangent et ça ça c'est ce qu'il faut
et le problème et le problème est l'ange
est ou non je ne mélange pas tout
mélanger tous et de l'insi souci parce
que non c'est pas de docteur je suis
désolé excusez moi lisez moi oui
d'accord ils vous racontent est
absolument n'importe quoi bien sûr mais
pourquoi il ya dire qu'on ait marqué
vous avez une sortir l'étoile jaune de
te raconter n'importe quoi
vous racontez n'importe où renée
la première la première chose que je
trouve inacceptables dans l'argument du
docteur c'est que on ne peut pas
utiliser le fait d'un exemple d'un
hôpital italien où on aurait choisi
entre deux et c'est possible dans la
mesure où je pourrai si on jouait à la
bataille est ce que vous essayez de
m'emmener dans un jeu de roy 13 bataille
machin picard au coeur qui me semble
totalement infantile et même enfantin
c'est que je pourrais vous opposer ce
que je ne vais pas faire encore que le
nombre d'enfants qui se sont suicidés
cette année car ça vous le prenez jamais
en compte six gendarmes et non non vous
venez comme vous êtes en béarnais par
l'armée et je viens aussi aux enfants et
que que vous soyez cyniquement crispé
sur cette maladie alors que les maladies
adjacentes
celles qui ont fait des ravages
psychologiques psychiatriques chez des
êtres à peu près sain le fait que des
enfants de 15 ans de 12 ans de 7 ans se
tranche la gorge se serre avec un lacet
la gorge pour quitter cette terre parce
qu'ils ne sont pas sortis depuis un an
le fait qu'on nous empêche de faire du
sport depuis un an
le fait qu'on sache que les mares que ne
servent à rien à l'extérieur qu'on sache
et vous vous nous avez quoi une sorte de
panique mortifère où il faudrait rester
sous cloche parce que des gens comme
vous ont considéré qu'elle est au moins
deux ans on avait la vie devant là je ne
veux plus entendre ce discours c'est
irresponsable un droit jean lortie
docteur n'avait le droit de pas avoir
entendu les gars comme moi je désire
c'est a très bien géré les vallons 80
balais les dix ans encore ils ont la vie
devant des accents et je trouve ça très
bien mis l'accent c'est très bien mais
vous vous les entoure et quant au futur
et gesvres pour plaire à leur garder les
enfants filles ou qu'on a été les
premiers jeux parallèles sur l'état
mental des malheureusement et qu'on a
dit malheureusement contrairement à sa
consoeur me posais les lecteurs
contrairement à ce que proposait raison
vous avez raison de soulever le
couvercle parce qu'ils avaient pris la
dimension du mental des français qui
étaient désastreux alors à l'épandage de
la générale et rabat de cette génération
de médecins l'enfant gâté qui ont oublié
quand ils ont commencé leurs études de
médecine de faire un peu de philosophie
de réfléchir ça donne en fait ce que
j'appelle moi des beaufs de la médecine
ce sont des gens voient la saison là
à j-1 succès par ce mec ça suffit mais
voilà ça suffit ça fait deux fois qu'on
avait tous la première fois on la bombe
dans la médecine et ça va bien on a
besoin à mon pote je suis mal si côtier
p2 alors bob de la médecine mc dira je
veux dire c'est vrai que j'ai pas le
temps que leur philosophie retraites des
ouvriers donc alors c'est bon le passé
que non mais ça va bien et j'ai connu et
je connais la période sur aussi manger
mou en fait jamais de sin faire médecine
en étant littéraire donc c'est bon qu'il
arrête de nous insulter ce type
franchement l'aller mais là je reviens à
ce moment vous un inter sa volt et vous
avez pas lourds entraînant pour lui si
vous admirez qui suit jour se suicider
vous en fichez vous êtes là c'est à dire
ça c'est la vérité par les dames aura
des morts on n'oppose pas un mot
d'italien qui choisissent en train un
homme de 55 ans à c'est le terrain dans
ce genre de débats cet argument là et
nulle part il est là pour faire faire
l'adversaire c'est cette fois un même
âge un monologue isabelle qu'est ce qui
se passe parce que moi honnêtement
j'espère et nous avaient pas revenir une
énième soit sur ce terrain là en disant
je suis ont fait leur temps qu'est-ce
que j'ai pas dit ça
tout le monde souffre pourquoi vous êtes
de l'eugénisme par voulait absolument ce
qui me désole de ce fait tous en soient
tous moi je trouve insupportable ce
discours ce que j'ai dit mais si j'ai
alors c'est la seleçao ne pas écouter
je trouve cette baisse relative et cela
aux yeux pas assez remaniée par ailleurs
pardon yann moix mais parler des kz2 de
marquage sanitaires non non mais cette
extrapolation sur le market sanitaires
tels que non c'est pas un marcassin
cinéma des années relève et tatouages
total sont nés en barres tombées à macao
on sait très bien ce que si on désigne
d'atouts et quelqu'un les candidats mais
là où tu es en train de faire un pas
vers yale sur un tatouage ou un marquage
sanitaires non hors du pas là je pense
d'abord que dont ma maison moi cet
excellent ammoniac j'entends bien que ce
soit excessif mais et c'est pour ça que
je m'indigne un citoyen n'est pas un
organisme biologique un citoyen c'est
tout le reste
la civilisation été construite autour du
fait que nous ne sommes pas de décor et
là on nous ramène à notre définition
corporelle strictes pour nous faire
entrer dans des restaurants des cinémas
c'est pas salé ghellab et là ne me
faisais pas ça les libertés c'est pas ça
la fraternité l'égalité la liberté le
faut des années cette foire avec tous
aux mêmes manoir ayants droit la drague
mais après je voudrais qu'on recompte
ses petits-enfants yann je vois pas le
rapport entre ces mais aussi parce que
justement quand on a des enfants par
exemple en les vaccinant les maximes
pour qu'il puisse aller relever son
niveau contre la veille sur moi ça veut
dire que nos enfants sont marqués ah non
vous aimez être extradé l'information
sur le valencien qui est désagréable
c'est pas le bac sans lui-même
extrapolation sur le passé ni terre
comme valérie et camilla belle je vais
être un peu beau recadrer un peu grillé
un videur vous n'êtes pas vacciné donc
vous ne rentrez pas dans une zone à
l'école on dit vous n'êtes pas vaccinés
contre la polio riz contre la rubéole
oreillons centre de loisirs c'est pas un
cinéma un restaurant mais peu importe ça
y est les personnes qui n'ont pas eu la
chance de se faire encore vaccinés sexe
que tous ceux qui n'ont pas eu de piston
qui n'ont pas encore l'âge il n'y a pas
je n'aime pas c'est une annonce qui va
nous regarder les autres allaient
s'amuser parce qu'on a là une aiguille
et pas les organes de minutes chocolat
ouais non c'est assez insupportable
d'entendre ce discours
ouais c'est vrai que 1 l'entendre
dégoiser vous êtes obligés de rester en
d1
non mais attendez c'est bon vendez votre
bouquin et puis oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai que c'est un peu énervant parce que
d'ailleurs que l'équipe ont paniqué
alors qu incontestablement le système
hospitalier étaient au taquet et ont
compté les morts ouais bien sûr jour le
taquet mais allez allez donc faire un
tour à l'image c'est bon donc là si je
veux bon l'ailé les gens effectivement
on n'en peut plus là ici affective on ça
va se rouvrir
on est à capimmec en réanimation alors
que quand on avait rouvert la première
fois on était rendu à 1500 là on est à 1
4006 les jean decon ça va redémarrer
si ça redémarre les mecs alors là je
peux dire que le moral des français là
bas ils rapportent qu'un suicide de
gamin il y en a un paquet là on à 4100
toi on était on était à 7000 grâce à
caen sa vraie mère quand on a fait le
plein tarif ouais ouais donc on est
vraiment à la rue et on c'est vrai que
bon là l'autre jour en plus ce mec la
salade qui me poursuit devant l'ordre
des médecins poursuivis parce que j'ai
dit que il s'est effectivement c'était
inclut un comportement d'abrutis que
d'inciter les gens à s'embrasser alors
que à ce moment là les arrêts nimation
en paca était plein et qu'on se
demandait si on allait pas confiné pas 4
donc j'ai dit que s'ils offrent ce type
là un comportement irresponsable
c'est beaucoup qu'on veut accélérer et
le gag c'est que moi ils peuvent te
placer son avocat qui porte plainte à
l'ordre et c'est à cause de ça que lord
me convoque alors si n'importe quel mec
est capable à chaque fois que il ya un
médecin qui l'a regardé de travers ou
qu'a dit un mot un peu déplacé on est
convoqué par des gens comme lui qui sont
complotistes qui croient pas aux vaccins
qui croient pas à un masque et cetera
qui incite les gens à s'embrasser alors
que l'airé à son plein
je peux vous dire que là ça me fout un
peu les boules quoi si là on n'est pas
protégé de ce côté là c'est absolument
infernal
il a le droit de donner son avis et
francis lalanne par bon en fait il ya
plein de gens qui dans le fond même si
lui il est un peu ils ont il en fait des
caisses il ya plein de gens qui pensent
comme lui tu as le droit d'appeler à la
révolution et vous n'êtes pas de troll
de traité d'abruti non plus facile quand
tu es à nice quand tu es à nice 1-1 chez
pull c'était oui dans paca le type il
assure une place tu sais que la
réanimation en paca est son plein que
les gens se disent on va être obligé de
isoler la région mais d'agglo confiner
la région colloghan il à l'été buisson a
toujours eu leur dis portait pas de
masque que mettez le à embrasser vous là
là vraiment c'est le c'est l'endroit
idéal pour ce pour ceux contaminés
qu'en est il dit ça tu veux la moelle et
les nommer mais mes copains réanimateur
qui n'en peuvent plus tu vois pas ce que
les mecs ça fait quinze mois qui sont
qui sont au taquet les internes de
médecine vous avez parlé des enfants
les internes en médecine actuellement
ici il ya un interne qui se suicident
tous les dix-huit jours tous les
dix-huit jours
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est vous
avez 22 23 24 ans vous avez pas d'heure
vous voyez les gens mourir vous pouvez
pas récupérer
c'est insupportable à entendre ce
discours là non mais moi j'en ai
ras-le-bol
je vois des gens connus m et plus qui
profite quand je vois des gens comme lui
qui profite de sa notoriété pour inciter
les gens à ceux contaminés mais
franchement ça me fout les boules bleues
effectivement ça m'énerve deux fois plus
alors j'espère que là moi j'ai refusé la
conciliation je serais sûrement convoqué
par la chambre département cas et c'est
aussi cela la fait compris l'ordre des
médecins j'espère et j'espère que ce
type là sera condamnée pour procédure
abusive
ces récits moi je maîtrise pas la chose
le problème n'est pas là le problème en
fait on le sait qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'humanité tout entière c'est pas
simplement la france la mort à laquelle
on ne s'était plus habituée depuis plus
de cinquante ou soixante ans soixante
dix ans est devenu tout d'un coup est
intolérable insupportable c'est à dire
que l'idée même de mourir avait disparu
de notre horizon et on s'est habitué
quasiment fait des numéros tél on avait
autour de nous des gens qui mouraient
mans n'avait pas eu la sensation qu'on
pouvait à mourir nous à tout moment
comme on l'a eue pendant virus même
pendant les actes terroristes on n'a pas
ça et du coup on s'est acclimaté
dangereusement au fait que la mort était
illégale illicite illégitime et
anormales se rappelle tout d'un coup de
notre mortalité a fait un effet boom
dans la société humaine et tout d'un
coup on a trouvé inadmissible que les
vaccins n'arrive pas plus vite
inadmissible que les hôpitaux soient
plaint tout le temps tu es devenu
inadmissible mais ce qu'on ne supporte
plus cyril et c'est pour ça qu'on est en
désaccord parce que francis lalanne il
fait ce qu'il veut moi je ne suis pas du
tout dans ce registre là et je pense que
avec le docteur
ils expriment tous les deux une
extrémité moi je suis au centre je dis
qu'on peut réfléchir calmement aux
choses et que tout simplement sans
souhaiter la mort de personne et de
faire différence entre la moindre vie la
mort c'est partie de la vie et cet
épisode de manière ultra violente nous
l'a rappelé et ça nous semble
insupportable ce rappel j'ai réservé
eliane vous viviez tout seul dans un
autre monde
enfin c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
un an la loi de mourir dignement il n'y
a pas d'âge pour sa nature boyer qui
encore j'ai travaillé il ya encore trois
semaines
laissez les gens de 80 ans qu'on va pas
chercher chez eux qui ont le coc vide
parce qu'on a plus de place dans les
réanimations c est qu on leur dit vous
restez chez vous et vous crevez vous
savez que le kobe tu quand vous en
mourrez vous en mourrez comme en amour
est étouffée donc je pense que c'est
être la pire des morts qu'on peut avoir
à 80 ans donc à un moment donné de quoi
vous parlez vous insultez les médecins
heureusement que les médecins et les
infirmiers télémédecine crack
qu'ordinairement ils n'en peuvent plus
vous avez de plus en plus on n'arrive
plus à recruter d'un fermier et après de
l'autre côté comment vous pouvez tenir
ce genre de propos par rapport à la vie
la mort ça n'a strictement rien à voir
l'urgence et on le voit bien aujourd'hui
en israël il ya plus de morts en
angleterre il ya plus de morts c'est de
se vacciner massivement donc appelé
appelé au vaccin
sa vie a rappelé aux devoirs civiques il
faut appeler au vaccin pour que son
protège et qu'on se protège tous et
qu'on sorte définitivement de ça mais je
veux dire moi mon père à 90 ans il a le
droit de vivre je suis désolé la sueur
aller chez le werder n'a jamais dit le
contraire donc en médiane la franchement
vous m'effrayé c'est à dire que vous
avez été lecture alizés vous êtes ont
écrit locke ce soir et j'ai dit non non
vous intellectualiser jamais 10 heures
une désinvolture total sur 1 pourquoi
c'est ton préoccupé de cette maladie qui
n'a fait que cent mille morts mais si
vous dites ça vous vous rendez pas
compte de ce que vous dit non il ya des
gens qui meurent ici on n'avait rien
fait sauf que les réfléchissez l'avion
n'avait rien fait ou on saurions-nous
passagers en serions nous y aurait des
centaines de milliers alors une on a
fait ce qu'on avait et vous vous dites
vous dit ce n'était rien ce n'était rien
oh oui c'est notre rapport à la mort qui
aujourd'hui est compliqué mais arrêtez
de farrell les prix c'est très
dangereuse que vous dites chargelègue
dangereux yade parce que l'un d'eux
juste y avait un malentendu total
alors je dis qu'à une disproportion ou
une disproportion totale entre la
gravité de la situation et la manière
dont on a réagi c'est à dire que vous
ayez les décisions politiques sur les
sept ou huit mois qui viennent
déroulez elles sont toutes
contradictoires lorsque il n'y a pas de
lisibilité dans des décisions politiques
et qu'il ya un spécialiste par jour
ducobu de la télévision ça décrit une
situation dont l'appel sans physique de
mouvements browniens cirque tout le
monde donnait un sens et donc il n'y a
pas de lisibilité et j'appelle panique
quand tout le monde donne son avis en
même temps et que personne ne converge
vers rien c'est ça que j'appelle la
panique et là où je vous rejoins mais
j'ai jamais dit le contraire c'est que
premièrement on a fait ce qu'on a pu et
heureusement qu'on l'a fait parce que
les pays qui n'ont rien fait c'est le
désastre le plus total
d'après ce qu'on a pu et là où je suis
totalement surpris et et vous allez voir
qu'un jour on va l'étudier ça en classe
c'est la manière dont on nous a pris
pour des imbéciles en nous faisant
accroire que telle ou telle chose était
vital pour annuler cette décision
quinze jours plus tard plutôt que de
nous faire découvrir la dangerosité
réelle du virus on essayait d'en
maquiller d'en inventer une en nous des
grès non un nombre de morts tous les
soirs or les chiffres ils ne veulent
rien dire parce que on aurait fait la
même chose avec la sclérose en plaques
on leur fait peur à tout le monde avec
la saison
elle mord ça veut rien dire pour vous je
suis également je dis simplement que
lorsqu'il ya des situations
exceptionnelles et c'en est une
il ne faut pas s'étonner qu'ils aient
des choix enfin il faut pas s'étonner
que les chiffres noirs ou les rails or
c'est ce que vous dites là ouais non
dire effectivement c'est vrai qu'au
début je les ai rappelés en tout début
au début effectivement on savait pas ce
qu'on connaissait pas ce virus on
connaissait pas sa dangerosité on
connaissait pas exactement sa
contagiosité donc y ait eu des mesures
qui ont été contradictoires on c'est
vrai que bon il ya eu l'épisode du
masque au départ il ya eu l'épisode des
tests au mois de septembre ou qu'on est
on n'était pas suffisamment prêt etc
il ya l'histoire des gens contestent et
qu'on renvoie chez eux une fois qu'ils
sont positifs isolé contaminer leurs
familles sans pouvoir à sans prévoir de
mesure d'isolement
tout ça c'est vrai que bon mais dans la
panique il ya eu quand même à u11
d'espoir génial c'est que les
industriels ont été capables de faire un
vaccin en un an
et que et que là et que là vraiment il
faut que les gens sax in mais qu' il
faut tenir compte aussi de l'évolution
de ce virus qui est en train de muter
qui peut se transformer dont on ne sait
pas si ces transformations bon résiste
aux vaccins etc pour qu'on est obligé de
dire aux gens au fait de golf continuer
à respecter les mesures barrières voyez
vos potes mais faites gaffe ne ne soyez
pas imprudent
alors quand je vois des gens qui incite
les autres à s'embrasser dans la rue a
pas porter de masque à dire que c'est
une connerie et c'est que vacciner c'est
dangereux parce que ça aussi il a dit
donc ça a effectivement cessé c'est pour
nous c'est insupportable parce que osé
dire que on découvre la mort là
actuellement vous savez quand vous êtes
médecin quand vous êtes étudiant en
médecine les mecs ils rentrent ils ont
19 20 ans 22 ans je parlais pas ces gens
là je vous explique les gens ils comment
ils découvrent ils découvrent la
fragilité de l'existence parce que quand
vous avez 19 20 ans vous pensez pas à
l'avant
les mecs ils découvrent l'existence y
découvre la fragilité de l'existence il
découvre la maladie et la mort
il découvre un truc dont on n'arrive pas
à sortir ce qu'il est j'entends et moi
je vois quand moi je vois que
actuellement un interne sur 18 ce
suicide
vous imaginez tous les dix-huit jours un
interne tous les dix jours qui se
suicident là moi je vois rouge quand on
tape sur les soignants et que et que les
mecs ose dire qu'ils en ont marre dit
que faut faire attention donc si vous
laissez pas du tout content qu'on puisse
demander aux gens s'ils sont vaccinés
parce que maintenant on sait pas ce
qu'on ne savait pas au départ encore un
quand les gens sont vaccinés ils
transmettent mois le virus mais vous
avez un tour qui favorise l'accession ne
savais pas ça gâte en or on le savait
pas 1
on savait également que sa protégée
contre les maladies graves
j'ai aussi est une ballade
renouvellement terme on ne sait pas si
le fc combien de temps durera l'humanité
cicero quand même s'il faudra par
vaincre les étudiants sont en avance en
marchant alors quand on parle quand
j'entends parler de contradictions c'est
vrai que d'autres
il ya entente quand il ya des médecins
qui entendent que les réanimations son
plein ce qu'il faut faire gaffe et que
et que effectivement le conseil
scientifique dont vivent tous fermés et
que mais que le président quand même qui
fait rentrer un psychiatre
je rappelle dans le conseil scientifique
parce qu'il a bien pris conscience que
le sol à la santé mentale des français
étaient en danger et qu'il permet de
rouvrir alors qu'il ya des médecins qui
nie il faut continuer encore affirmé et
parce qu'il faut donner un peu d'air aux
français sur ces autos d'hier
on est dans une course de fond ça dont
on connaît pas la fin et mesquin et
c'est continuer à nous battre
voilà tout le problème qu'au fric veille
alors pourquoi vous utilisez un toit
leveaux a dû marquage signifie que ce
que je n'arrive pas à faire mais quand
même je dise il a suffi d'un pc ou quoi
mais dit pas de bêtise
les ayatollahs du doigt c'est gratuit
si le sanitaire si on veut par exemple
ne s'inscrit pas comme ça si on n'est
pas vacciné mais on a un pcr et dans les
airs de moins de niamey la première
raison c'est d'abord vous par francis
hans et francis lalanne moi je suis
favorable au vaccin depuis le départ à
1000% et d'ailleurs si les gens se
faisaient vacciner y aurait pas le débat
sur le pacs sanitaire est ce que ça fait
c'est parce que les patients vaccinés
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas de dose la
vaccin il a raison parce qu'on à moi je
rappelle dans une pharmacie
mon pharmacien m'a dit j'ai jeté mais
j'étais désolé sera donné qu'à
je trouve ça aussi aberrant mais le
problème n'est pas là je vaccine douze
mecs déjà je trouve cependant avec de
vertigineux et personne n'a l'air de
s'en inquiéter
je suis favorable aux vaccins 1000% je
dis simplement la violence que c'est
quand vous n'avez pas encore pu vous
faire vacciner mais que vous le
souhaitez que vous voyez des gens
entrent dans des restaurants ou des
cinémas parce que biologiquement vous
n'avez pas été détectés par l'état comme
étant normal c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement dangereux et oui ce sera
terminé
ça rejoint l'amer baril mais oui c'est
une sorte de barnes et ses spectateurs
s'il vous plaît week-end à 32% non à 68%
n'allait pas s'arrêter de vivre donc
demain les terrasses vont réouvrir y
aurait je pense qu'on sera en début
d'émission en terrasse je crois qu'on
sera avec le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent en terrasse
pour inaugurer l'ouverture des terrasses